-Good evening. I'm Seth Myers,
and this is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
That's -- Get to the news.
[ Laughter ]
Look, I'm reacting
to the fact...
A lot of people are mad...
-Yeah?
-...that I say, "How's everybody
doing tonight,"
and then I don't wait
long enough for an answer.
And now, I'm in my head
about it.
-Stop reading that.
-What?
-Stop reading that stuff.
-The comments?
-Yeah.
-I have to read the comments
for Corrections.
If you don't know
what Corrections are,
it is an extra thing we do
not on the show.
It's available on YouTube.
And I don't need you
telling me...
President Biden misspoke
earlier this week
during his visit to Michigan
and referred to his father
who was a salesperson,
as a coal miner.
I'm sorry, but how the hel
do you mix those two up?
That's like saying,
"And my mom was a homemaker --
oh, wait, astronaut."
The White House said yesterday
that President Biden spoke
to Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu
and told him that the U.S.
"expected a significant
deescalation
and a path to a cease fire
with Hamas."
A path?
To a cease fire?
You don't need a path.
Everything you have to do
is in the name.
"Cease fire."
What else did he say?
"Let's end this thing, BB.
Now, I'm gonna count
to a million."
While discussing the ongoing
criminal investigation
into the Trump organizatio
and in a new interview,
Former President Trump's
ex-personal lawyer Michael Cohen
said that Trump will
flip on everyone,
including "his children."
Said Trump, "Alleged children.
Microsoft co-founder Bill Gate
made his first
public appearance yesterda
since his divorce announcement
and I don't want to assume
how he's doing,
but, oh, my God, he got bangs.
[ Chuckles ]
According to a recent survey
nearly 30% of Americans
are hesitant to invest
in Bitcoin
because they do not understand
cryptocurrency,
and another 30% are hesitant
to invest because they do.
Authorities in the UK
recently arrested two men
who were allegedly running
a marijuana distribution sit
out of an abandoned bingo hall
Police became suspicious
when someone under 70
went into a bingo hall.
Drone companies
are reportedly preparing
to deliver coronavirus vaccine
to Americans
in rural communities.
Ah, yes -- nothing will increase
rural Americans' faith
in the vaccines
like having them delivered
by a corporate drone.
A new online game has launched
that challenges users
to try to spend all
of Tesla CEO Elon Musk's
$166 billion fortune
in 30 seconds.
"Done!" said someone getting
a six-pack of razors.
A zoo in Germany
announced yesterday
that its newest polar bear cub
is the product of breeding
between two polar bear siblings.
Wow, they really do treat
their animals like royalty
According to a new study,
the average person
spends around $100 every month
on their pet.
It's what the cat charges.
"Look, I'm not gonna
walk over to you for free.
I hate you."
Authorities in
New Hampshire yesterday
charged a man
for allegedly detonating
80 pounds of explosives
at a gender reveal party.
Even scarier, soon he'll b
charged with raising a child
And finally,
according to a new study,
dating apps like Bumble,
Grindr, and Tinder
are in the top 15%
of battery-draining apps
on smartphones.
Even more draining --
the people you meet on them.
And that, you guys,
was the monologue.